This is the lab, basically,
where we do all of our,
all of our mixing and potion-ing.
So as you can probably
tell, we've mixed a few
batches of blood on this counter,
but I can take you through
a batch if you like.
Most of your run-of-the-mill bloods
start off with corn syrup,
you know, it gives it a little
viscosity, if it was going to
be a regular everyday blood,
we'd put some soap in it,
because that helps it clean up.
Interviewer: Oh really?
Pam: Like when you, when
you get it in your wardrobe
or something, it helps it wash out.
If you were to just put
color in here right now,
it would kinda come out
looking like cherry cough syrup
because blood is a little
opaque, it's not completely
see-through, so we add an opacifier to it,
to make it opaque before
we start to color it.
So, basically, what you get
is kind of this white-looking
slurry, then we can start to color it.
And we go through a lot of food coloring.
Obviously, the base is red.
Now, you're never really going
to get to a really realistic
blood red with just red food color,
so what we do is we add a little blue,
or black, and then that
gives us a little depth.
So now you know, it looks more like
your classic, classic blood.
Now, we can take this, and take
it out here and do a little
something with it if you like.
Interviewer: Yeah, sure.
Pam: So we can do the, maybe
a blood spray, and maybe the
you know, classic blow out the
back of your head on the wall
kind of thing, if you want?
(Laughs)
Interviewer: Yeah, sure!
Pam: For this, sometimes,
you'd hide them behind
somebody, and then, you know,
at the moment where they
get shot in the head, then
splat against the wall.
Three, two, one...
Now if we do more pressure,
then it's a little more violent.
Interviewer: Right.
Okay yeah go for it.
Okay, three, two, one.
(laughs)
No!
Wow, that is brutal.
So this is going to be more directed.
Interviewer: Okay.
Pam: That's for when you
get sliced in the neck and--
(laughs)
it sprays, (laughs) it sprays out with--
Interviewer: Right.
Pam: So if you're doing
blood on a floor that you
can't really get blood on
because it's gonna stain,
or on carpet or you know stuff like that,
then we make these rubber ones
that we can just throw down
on the floor and then pick up and go away.